- Uh, Ch..
(Welsh country music)
- I had no idea that they had
their own language (laughs)
- Aren't like all the royalty
princes and princesses of Wales?
- [Voiceover] Tywyn
- Honestly looks to me like a little baby
just got mad at the keyboard.
It went like this.
- Tywin, that's how you spell
Tywin Lannister, isn't it?
- Tun?
- Taiwan! No, it's not Taiwan.
- Tywyn (bell rings)
(gasps) Oh my God!
- Why do the two "y"'s
make different noises?
- [Voiceover] Crymych
- This looks like a game
of Hangman that I lost.
Right? Like there are a bunch of dashes
and I just didn't get the vowels.
- Do ya cry much?
That looks like an advertisement
for an anti-depressant.
- Searmych?
- The accent is key. Creimooch.
- So the "y" is an "uh"...
- I think I could mess with this language.
- [Voiceover] Ynysybwl
- What?! What is that?
- (laughs)
- That looks like a rapper's name.
Like Young Souble.
- Yessebellme.
- Enisebul
- Nice Boy.
- [Voiceover] Ynysybwl.
- Okay.
- Sounds like what you
say when you're cold.
You're just like "Brrr." Ynysybrrrr.
- [Voiceover] Ysbyty Ystwyth
- The top looks like a dumb start-up
that you'd see in Silicon Valley.
- Eyes-beady-vigith?
- Wobydy Wosidey.
- Ispitty Istwith.
- [Voiceover] Ysbyty Ystwyth
- What? I'm sorry, what?
- That's so cool! This
is the coolest language.
- [Voiceover]
LLanfairpwllgwyngyllgogerychwyrndrobwylll-
lantysiliogogogoch
- (screams)
- Yeah, no, I'm just
gonna go. I'm just done.
- (laughs)
- This is one word?
- Were they drunk when
they named this town?
This is a town?
- Lahnfairpwhygwangwyelgogurch
- Sherwindrabbellalalalantisigiggugugoch.
Nailed it!
- [voiceover] LLanfairpwllgwyngyll-
gogerychwyrndrobwyllllantysiliogogogoch
- (laughs) What?! No!
- That sounds like you're making this up.
- It sounds like an ancient
prayer, more than a town.
- I think Welsh people value city names.
I think in America it's
kind of an after-thought.
- I still want to go to Wales,
'cause it's beautiful, I hear.
I don't wanna ever have to
follow directions there.
- It's very interesting that
it's so close to England
and we associate it
with being like England
but it's so very different.